EXCLUSIV
ER PRESIDENT.
FLORIDA TONIGHMID
ON 37 CRIMAL CUMENTS, DISSEMINA
RETENOBSTRUCTION.
FRONT"E FLORIDA.P OFHILAWYERL T
NOW BE THE IMPORTANTTHING IN LIS
ERIN, HE HER H
RESORT IN DORAL,, ABOUT OR SO.
HE WENT UPSTAIRS WITH HIS SON
AND HIS TE OLAWYERS, A THE
S EN
AND WE HADN'T SEENIL
JUST ABOUT 7:00 WHERN SHOW
YOU THIS VIDEO THAT I JUSTIM IN
E ELEVATOR TO GOO DINNER Y INIST
RESTAURANT IN RESORT.AD GONE IN
ABOUT A HALF AN HOUROR
NC I
HE WAS OBVIO MEE HIM.
D  OPEOPLE
RESTAURANT, MANYF E NSTHSHOUTIN
HO FEEL RROW?OME THUMBS-UP ACTI
WITH THE REST OF TM.
THEN HE OP CAN
RES WI
LLY PAUSED AND TOOK
S THLE, HEY DIA
LIVING.
AND THEN HE WENT OS WAY TO
THE BACK ROOM OF THE RWHDINE WI.
BUT IT WAS INTERESTING
SPS.R IN THEAYE SEEMED A
BISOIDO EVERYBODY HOW ARE YOU
QUIETER.CHEERYNDES AND
HAD A VERY CONFIDENT AIR ABOUT
HIM ON T EVEAT IS
BVERY, RY CRITICAL DAP.
CERTAINLY IS. RANDI
N VIDEN.
IT IS INTERESTINNT, MRENT,
MR. PRESIDENT, NGTURES
CONTRASTS THE KINDF CONFIDENCE
LEMNITY  THE DAY
THIS, IT'S LIKE OXYGEN.
T GIVES HIM LIFEDOL E .
SO THERE ARE PEOPLE THERE WHO
IN HOPES OTHERE AND SPEND A LOT
WITH HIM.
IIKTHR
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A SECONDT F
HISTORI A OF ITSELF.
HEROJECTEDONGHBEINK TOMORROW YO
AND IT'S INTO, FURY, THE DEPART
JCRATS ARE
COMING A IT'S NOT .
T'S JUSTHEE  LIK GOK, I'M COMIN.
THIS IS >> WT ITT R T GETSD
SOE KNOW'S GOING T
BE, TOMORROW HE'LL BN
COURT, AND HE WILLBLDO
THIS AINGIA.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY NEEDS
LOOK AROUND FOBODY ELSE TO
ENTHLL I HAVE TO SAY.
PULL  CONVERSATION I HAD WITHT
OTHECOMMENT ABOUT THE NT F
S TO BE NGLE
MOST IMPORTANT T IN
LIFE.
IT IS A PERILOUS PLACE TO BE.
THAT?SIDT
>> HE SH.OUS AMF
WE TO HAVEE
UNS SE, THERE'S BEEN A COMMENTA
HAVE TWO JTEMS IPPARENY ONLY WHR
WE'VE HAD FFN PE
C
UPTION BY THE DOJ.
EVY SINGLE WS WILL
BE USED AGAINST HIM IN
OF L.MIGHT, NOT THERE'S A
WILLE Y
INTENNGOM 2016.
STEPS.
ALL OF TS
SELF-INFLICTED WOUND.
WHAT
O OUTOUT
DO YOU WORK WITH
CONE HAND,HA BDO YOU'RE SPEAKING
T, TO FOLL H
ALSO BE ABLTO
DEFEND H
>> I JUST WANT T
SOMETHIN GAME, G YE
THINGS.
ARE YOU READY FOR MY LITTL
GAME?
I MESHG ILT THE
'S ON.
SHDIULL WELL
WOULD PUT AMERICAN LIVES AT RISY
E.
HILLY S EMAIL SCANDAL,
DISQUALIFIES HER FROM THE
IDENCY.
ONE GUESS.
ON.GO
THEN I WAS  PRESIDENT
LITTLERENTLY.RAVITS --T ME ASK A
NYONE AROUND DEIS? DO THLL
RTS NO OT >>HAQUESTI
BECAUSE R
LIFE EVENTS GOING ONEE HIM OUT L
AND TH S THEIR BE
STRATEGY, SLASH, POLIT ICH IS T.
ESNG
THINGS, FIGHTING FOR YOULI
POLITICALLY.
THE SUE GRAVITY OFH OF THEE
ENORMOUS.
F LAUGW HICH I
IS SCHEDULED TOO TO
Y
LAUGH TOF LOOK  EVIDER OPJONAT
S DEFENDED D
NOT UGO SION SAY TROUB YAN
IOUSLBEE
DOESN'T N THE PR AND
DOES GO TO TRIAL, HE'
>> AND, BY
TOT'S ER, HE ANNOUNCED HISIDACEY
E RTF WAS BECAUSE HE KNEW THAT .
AND, IN E GETS T GOEO BE
ELTEPRESIDENT, THAT'S THE
BEST LAL BACKSTOP THE HAT I THI
THE OUTSET.
>> IF HE WERE TO BECOME THE
PRESIDENT  T
IT'S THE CASE  AWA
THE OPINIS THAT YOU CAINDICT A
OFFICE. TOECUTION,TOLDYO
O THE LARGER POINT HERE AS
REPUBLICANSE
CRITIZ VANCES, THE RELITIF
20IS DOES PROVIDHIA ABOUSI
D  IF THE  SOME
SSEY THATGGY, YOU
DN'T WANT ME IN THE
R THAT ACTUAE
K     THE NEEDLE THE DOJ IST G.
VEARLY, TRMS WE RDS REI DO
RUNNRY
MENTS.
I PEDOEP FALLIN PRIMY VO
STRONGLY PREFER THAT HE TAIS PL
COUNTRY IN ANOTHERERM, THEY
WERE FAR LESS INTERESTED IN G AT
FRNER, OF COURSE.PE
STUFF.OMETHING ABOUT THI
CHALLEIN THIS INS